the left knows the truth with a capital
T the truth is if you're a white male
you're guilty if you're a woman of color
you're a victim Alan Dershowitz is one
of the most famous legal minds of the
last half century after graduating first
in class from Yale Law School in 1962
Dershowitz clerked for Supreme Court
justice Arthur Goldberg just a few years
later at 28 he became the youngest
person at the time to ever become a
tenured professor at Harvard he then
went on to defend some of the most
high-profile defendants in history of
the country from OJ Simpson and Jeffrey
Epstein to Harvey Weinstein and Mike
Tyson Alan Dershowitz has played a
significant role in crafting the
defenses of major figures accused of a
litany of heinous crimes but the one
that has arguably drawn the most
controversy is one in which his
defendant was not accused of any actual
crime in January 2020 during the
impeachment trial of President Trump
Allen took the stage to present the case
against impeachment Allen being a
lifelong Liberal Democrat and a 2016
Hillary Clinton supporter believes
everyone has a right to defense in a
court of law even Donald Trump Ellen and
I will discuss his rules on deciding
which clients to represent how the media
deeply misrepresented his case against
impeachment his new book guilt by
accusation the challenge of proving
innocence in the age of me2 as well as
whether or not Oh Jay did it
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the Ben Shapiro
show Sunday special today we are joined
by Professor Alan Dershowitz just a
reminder we'll be doing some bonus
questions with professor Dershowitz the
only way to get access to that part of
the conversation is to pay us money and
become a subscriber go over to Daley
we're calm become a subscriber you
access to all of the full conversations
with every one of our awesome guests
professor Dershowitz thanks so much for
stopping by my pleasure thank you when
we start with the obvious question how
did you a defense attorney best known
for being a lifelong Democrat and
defending who a lot of people would
consider on the Republicans to be
criminals how do you end up a hero of
the right how did this happen I
shouldn't be a hero the right any more
than I should have been a hero of the
left when I defended many people who
were left wingers I've always been a
neutral civil libertarian sometimes my
civil liberties lands on the side of the
left and then they love me and then
sometimes my civil liberties lands on
the side of the right and they love me
and the other side hates me for example
I started writing my book about
impeachment when Hillary Clinton looked
like she was gonna be elected and the
name of the book was called
the case against impeaching Hillary
Clinton I would have written the same
book had she been elected except they
would have built the statue to me on
Martha's Vineyard and I'd be the hero of
the left today but I make the same
argument just change the name of the
book from Clinton to Trump and now I've
hated by the hard left and loved by the
right I deserve neither a civil
libertarian shouldn't be loved or hated
by anybody but people who deeply believe
in civil liberties due process shoe on
the other foot test neutral principles
so do you think that something has
happened within the Democratic Party
that has changed because again it wasn't
just that you were a Democrat for for
most of your career still a Democrat
presumably the the real question is what
has changed such that the hatred for you
is so strong is it just the association
with Trump or did start before the X it
feels like it started a little bit
before that is I think so I think that
today the Democratic Party if you want
to be a full-on member you have to buy
everything they say and everything they
do and I'm just not that kind of a
person and I put politics way behind
civil liberties due process the
Constitution and so I think within a few
years it became obvious I wasn't their
guy and I'm treated like a traitor you
know
they don't hate J Sokolow or Pat's
baloney biggest or ten store it's
expected but me I'm a Liberal Democrat
how dare I defend the president bops
from yesterday said it was disgraceful
that I would defend the worst president
in the history of the country as if that
fact even if I believed it to be so
would influence my decision I defended
the worst criminals the worst people I
defended the right of Nazis to march
through Skokie I defended the rights of
Communists when I was in college even
though I hated communism that's what a
civil libertarian does I know now
Bernie's gonna be elected I mean that's
a bad decision but in any case I want to
ask you in one second about the about
sort of the future of the Democratic
Party considering that they're casting
out people like you but first even
though we're talking with Alan
Dershowitz let me be real about this
there's lots of crime lots of crime
everywhere and this is particularly true
in Los Angeles where governance is
terrible I know in my neighborhood we've
had a series of breaking entering crimes
it's really bad this is why I rely on
ring to keep my property safe not only
does the ring app allow me to know when
there's crime in my area but also ring
gives you protection at every corner it
helps you create custom affordable
security from your home rings video
doorbells let you answer the door and
check in on your home anytime from
anywhere so you can protect your family
pets property with rings outdoor
security cameras you can check in on
every part of your house so you'll never
miss a moment ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world and the text motion when people
come onto your property you get
notifications on your phone your tablet
your PC you can see here and speak to
visitors in real time from anywhere and
get peace of mind knowing that your
loved ones are safe get a special offer
on the ring Welcome kit when you go to
ring calm slash Ben welcome kit includes
the ring video doorbell to and chime pro
it's all you need to start building
custom security for your home today just
head on over to ring comm slash Ben
that's ringing comm slash Ben so let's
talk about the fact that since you're
now an outcast you've said before that
you have a house on Martha's Vineyard
but no one will talk to you over at
Martha's Vineyard do you think that the
Democratic Party it has a future if they
keep throwing out people who are middle
left or or center or is it possible that
they that their theory which seems to be
a burgeoning demographic majority based
on various victim groups that they can
sort of agglomerate together that that
that is actually a strategy for an
electoral successful that
be the worst the worst thing would be
for the Democratic Party to succeed as a
hard left identity politics
intersectionality party a combination of
people with grievances that would be
with the worst thing I would hope that
the Democrats would recognize that the
fate and the future of America lies with
the center I'm writing a new book now
called why I left the left but couldn't
join the right the case for a vibrant
center you know in the old day I would
have conversations like I'm having with
you with Bill Buckley and he called me
his favorite liberal I was his favorite
he was my favorite conservative we would
have good rational conversations we
disagreed about fundamental issues but
we could talk to each other can't do
that today with Democrats when I did my
argument in front of the Senate nobody
ever took it on on the merits Larry
tribe said it was bonkers people said I
was getting senile people attacked me
personally I wasn't a scholar in
constitutional law even though I taught
constitutional Criminal Procedure
through 50 years in constitutional
litigation I wrote books on the subject
if I had been a Hillary Clinton side if
she had been impeached I'd be the
greatest scholar in the history of
constitutional law according to the left
but they don't like where I came down in
this case so they attacked me personally
the ad hominem czar inexcusable so let's
talk about the the case that you made in
front of the Senate which of course
brought the the full weight of the
Democrats the Democrats in the press but
I repeat myself to bear on you the the
case that you made in front of the
Senate is not the case that CNN said you
made in front of the Senate they say the
case that CNN said they made in front of
the Senate was effectively that if a
politician of any sort does something in
pursuit of their own reelection
then this is not impeachable activity
now I saw that clip of you and I
immediately who had been taken out of
context because first of all it's an
idiotic argument and you're not an idiot
and second of all because CNN was saying
at night and CNN has some problems with
taking people out of context what is the
argument that you were actually making
and how did they twist that argument
well it wasn't taken out of context
that's happens all the time
it was doctored it was as if i said the
following let me tell you now what I
don't believe I don't believe a
president seeking reelection can do
anything
and CNN ran a president seeking
re-election can do
thing excluding the fact that I said
this is what I don't believe in the
paragraph before the quote that they
used I said if a president engages in
anything illegal
if the quid pro quo is illegal that
isn't peach ball I talked about corrupt
motive I talked about kickbacks I said
in my whole hour and ten minute speech
of the Senate if the president commits
anything which is criminal like akin to
treason or bribery he can be impeached
and so what CNN did is they took all of
that out and they made it sound like I
was saying and then you had these idiots
on CNN people like Paul Begala
who said basically what I said as a
president can do anything illegal
some said I said a president could shoot
his opponent a president could lock up
all the Democrats a president could
tamper with voting machines it's exactly
the opposite and then Joe Lockhart again
another liar said what I said is like
what muscle Eenie Hitler and Stalin
would say and I supported genocide look
either they didn't know what I said I
don't think that's the case I suspect
that what happened is and it's more than
a suspicion it's based on information
that I have is that hooker the head of
CNN made a willful deliberate decision
to have me say something that sounded
idiotic in order to hurt my credibility
on the an hour and 10 speech that I made
in front of the Senate and they
deliberately omitted what I had said
about criminal conduct to make it sound
like I was saying a president can do
anything and then everybody followed
suit everybody on CNN said that's what
their show it said and they knew I
didn't think that the point that I
immediately knew that you were making
because it's a point that I've made
myself and it is an obvious point
because the counterpoint is is
completely idiotic
which is that if a president does a
thing that is within his legal power to
do and that is tainted by his own
self-interest but is it is legal power
to do this thing but he also has a
self-interest as either a combined
motive or a secondary motive that's not
impeachable because that's just called
politics and every politician does that
where every time Barack Obama did
anything that was within his power to do
with an eye toward reelection that was
called his first term and to pretend
that that's impeachable activity which
is what the Democrats effectively were
doing is not
picha by example okay that example I
said let's assume the following
president Obama promises he's going to
bomb Syrian military if they use
chemical weapons they use chemical
weapons
his advisor comes in and says wait a
minute before you start bombing think
about what it will do to your election
the left will turn against you and and
and Obama's oh my god really I shouldn't
bomb I'll break my promise well that'd
be impeachable of course not and I don't
limit it to presidents I said it any
elected official always has mixed
motives they care about the national
interest but they always have an eye on
their political future and all I said
was if a president has one eye on his
reelect ability because he thinks his
electability is in the national interest
that can turn innocent conduct within
his power into an impeachable offense
there is nobody who would disagree with
that yet Adam Schiff pretended to
disagree with it nabla pretended to
disagree with it Schumer pretended to
disagree with it all three of them were
lying through their teeth and I wrote
that in The Wall Street Journal I got a
lot of criticism how dare you challenge
the motives of people well I am
challenging their motives and the as
soon as this thing broke the the first
reaction that I had was that the the
question in the end was going to be
about president Trump's motives if it
came out that he had said to John Bolton
for example that Bowman testified and
then he had said openly the reason that
I did this specifically is because I
want to knock Joe Biden out for purposes
of the 2020 election then that would
have been in people conduct but if he
had an eye back toward 2016 and he was
saying I want everything in 2016 looked
at because it bothers me annoys me and I
think it's in the national interest and
even if that was badly informed as some
of that stuff was the CrowdStrike stuff
and all the rest of it then that is not
impeachable that's just what we call bad
judgment and he's up for election and
that's why we decide who to vote for
based on bad judgment but that's not
impeachable conduct the other example I
gave is Joe Biden says unless you fire
the prosecutor I'm withholding a billion
dollars 90% of his mind was on the
national interest but what if in the
back of his mind he said you know maybe
it'll help my kid he works for asthma
maybe it'll call off the investigation
that wouldn't change his innocent
conduct into culpable conduct doesn't
matter with a president vice-president
or anybody else every politician
always has mixed motives that's what I
said everybody understood it they look
me in the eye they knew what I said and
then they deliberately lied about what I
said so moving forward when it comes to
impeachment given given the fact that
the Democrats didn't receive a single
Republican vote on on impeachment
well they got Mitt Romney on one charge
but they didn't they didn't receive any
other votes on impeachment do you think
that impeachment is still a viable power
under the Constitution what would a
president really have to do and be
caught doing in order to be impeached
Richard Nixon very simple he's the only
case in American history where a
president should have been impeached he
committed repeated crimes even when he
was being impeached and I favored his
impeachment I was on the national board
of the ACLU and I asked the ACLU to
oppose the way he was being treated they
named him as an unindicted
co-conspirator unfair if you're named as
an unindicted co-conspirator you can't
fight back you don't get a trial so as a
civil libertarian who favored his
impeachment I opposed that back in the
1960s look 70s you could argue about
anything about me but one thing you
can't argue about is my consistency I've
been absolutely consistent since the day
I started to be an adult when I fought
against censorship of communism at
Brooklyn College and I fought against
censorship during the Vietnam War I
never care which side it comes down on
right left-center
Republican Democrat I always care about
civil liberties and people understand
that but they pretend that I've changed
suddenly have become a reactionary right
winger instead of the liberal left
winger that I always that does feel like
a difference in moral system that has
happened in the United States I mean it
used to be even when I was growing up
that people would say it's a free
country you can sort of do what you want
and people don't tend to use that phrase
too much anymore there's a lot of talk
about things that you shouldn't say
maybe you should be pushed into saying
them or things that you or or the other
factors that are supposed to attend to
justice beyond your own individual case
you talk about a lot of this in guilt by
accusation but this came out most
famously during the Cavanaugh hearings
when it seemed as though the evidentiary
necessity to prove a case against
justice Cavanaugh was completely thrown
by the wayside by the media the mere
accusation was enough to slime him
because obviously he was a white man in
a position of privilege and power as
opposed to a woman who apparently he who
alleged that he had abused her without
not only no evidence but every single
piece of evidence that she tried
to stack up immediately fell apart
including people she said it we're at
the party in which he somehow wronged
her saying that they weren't at that
party and the party never took place and
still we're told that Kavanagh is some
sort of race right well you know in the
Columbia School of Journalism had me
interviewed for the Journal of Columbia
Journalism supposed to be they you know
the the paradigm the interviewer said
women you can't be a victim of a false
accusation you're a white old male I
mean that's the way journalists now
approach this problem it's all identity
politics doesn't matter what the
evidence is it matters who you are not
who you are what you are what your
identity is that determines whether you
get free speech whether you have trigger
warnings whether you are silenced
whether you're allowed to speak on
campus like the two of us have all kinds
of difficulties speaking on campus it
has nothing to do with our ideas they
refuse to take us on based on our ideas
it's all about who you are how dare you
exercise your white privilege by coming
on campus and telling us what you think
so what do you think the future is for
for due process I mean that that's the
most basic right that we have is this
right to due process the right to be
treated according to the circumstance of
our case and be judged on the merits of
the case as opposed to what you think of
me as a human being but more importantly
what you think of my group identity as a
human being that seems like it's going
completely by the way something there
were as I say about Kavanagh there were
full articles written about because he
was a powerful white male he should not
be given due process he didn't deserve
due process and you've seen the
definition of racism itself morph and
changed
formally people who used to say racism
was discrimination on the basis of race
will now say that it's discriminatory
intent on the basis of race combined
with power which of course immediately
suggests that if you're a member of a
victimized group that you can't be a
racist or a sexist or any other is you
can't be an anti-semite either if you're
a member of an oppressed group no
there's no question about that look deep
down not very many people care about due
process people use due process and free
speech for me but not for thee they
generally tend to support it when it
helps their side when I was growing up
it was the Liberals who wanted free
speech because the Conservatives the
right-wingers were suppressing free
speech on campus particularly among a
communists today it's the conservatives
who want free speech because their
rights are being violated what we need
are a core of people who support due
process and free speech regardless of
who benefits and who loses the number of
those people are are very small now I
have to tell you thank God for
conservatives because I think
conservatives now have come to
appreciate more than in the past the
virtues of due process fairness free
speech dialogue and all the rest of the
catalog of liberties and civil liberties
that I grew up taking for granted so in
a second I want to ask you about guilt
by accusation and the extent of the of
the pushing aside of due process
particularly the me2 movement now ask
about that one second first let's talk
about the importance of preserving your
memories without your memories what are
you your memories are incredibly
important to making you who you are as a
person and here's the problem you can
instantly lose those memories if they're
out in your garage you got a bunch of
old film reels what exactly are those
doing out there you've got a bunch of
old VHS tapes you don't even have a VCR
anymore you've got old photos but
they're getting waterlogged well why not
take all that stuff and get it digitized
this is where legacy box comes in legacy
box is a way for you to easily and
affordably digitally preserve your past
the process from start to finish it's
incredibly easy you just pack it up and
send it over there Team digitizes
everything by hand and then you receive
perfectly preserved digital copies on a
thumb drive DVD or the cloud ready to
watch share and enjoy plus they keep you
up to date with regular email updates
throughout the digitizing process legacy
box is the world's largest digitizer of
home movies and photos and they've
helped over 750 thousand families
digitally preserve their past I've been
using legacy box with myself my parent
said a bunch of old stuff out in the
garage I took all of it I'm sending it
in to legacy box I can't wait to see
what it looks like once it's done with
its digital preservation get started
preserving your past today go to legacy
box comm slash Ben to get an incredible
40 percent off your first order
buy today to take advantage of this
exclusive offer and then send in when
you're ready go to legacy box comm slash
Ben and save 40 percent while supplies
last okay so let's talk about the me2
movement it's it's been fascinating to
watch the boundaries of the meets you
movement move so I am somebody who is
obviously very social admirable just you
I'm very socially conservative I've
always been I'm the purest person I know
when it comes to matters like this I was
a virgin until I was married like the
whole day well you're the only other one
right
you know we didn't have learner's
permits for marriage like learn the
night you were met so with that said you
know the kind of general take of the
meets you movement which is that women
ought to be treated like human beings
and IP two pieces of meat is something
for which I was of course very
sympathetic but then as I watched the
standards what meets you constituted
move radically and the lines move
radically and the attempt to remove all
gradations of misconduct so making a
sexist remark in the office was now
considered a kin to rape or in
accusation was considered pure evidence
that this thing happened because of
course women don't lie there's one
genetic there's a genetic rule that
women are born with the predisposition
genetically always to tell the truth and
men particularly white men are born with
a genetic predisposition to lie I mean
they believe on women movement it's like
this is not just first-year criminal law
which is they that believe all anybody
is the stupidest thing in the world but
it's basic logic of course you'd never
believe all anybody based on their group
identity you would even believe all
rabbis or believe all priests why in the
world would you believe all anybody but
that has become the basis of the me2
movement and it's led to this idea again
that based on your victim group status
in this case the victims being women
particularly that you ought to be
believed on the basis of an accusation
alone and obviously since you are the
expert in criminal law this is
incredibly dangerous and when people
suggest that there are no bad
accusations of rape or evidence free
accusations of rape or sexual assault or
sexual misconduct that obviously is not
true
of course now I never met the woman ever
under any circumstances who accused me
we discovered hidden emails that she
tried to hide with her lawyers in which
she admit she never met me a hidden
manuscript which was sealed in which she
says she saw me once speaking to Jeffrey
Epstein about business but never met me
told the FBI she never had sex with me
told her best friends she never met me
or knew me her lawyer on tape recorded
says she's wrong simply wrong she
couldn't possibly have met you in the
places she said she met you an FBI
report concluded by the former director
of the FBI Louis Freeh that the whole
story was made up and it all went away
the judge struck it
lawyers with druid admitted they were
wrong and filing it and then Along Came
their me to movement and suddenly the
false accusation known to be false is
enough to get me cancelled speaking at
the 92nd Street Y the 92nd Street Y
where I've spoken at more than anybody
but elie wiesel suddenly said i can't
speak about my book defending Israel at
the 92nd Street Y because although they
know I didn't do anything wrong there's
an accusation and the accusation is
trouble and we don't want trouble so you
can't ever speak here again so what
should we do about that in the social
sphere because that's really what we're
talking about here and the criminal law
sphere obviously you're not in the dock
you haven't been accused formally of
anything I wish I were you know I wrote
an op-ed for The Wall Street Journal
saying to the FBI please investigate me
criminally conduct the criminal
investigation that's the only way I can
possibly clear myself you know the rule
is so absurd now she can accuse me of
anything she can accuse me of having sex
with her when she is 2 years old she
could accuse me of anything and as long
as she does it in papers that are law
papers she is exempt from being sued for
defamation but if I then deny it she can
sue me for defamation because by denying
it I have called her a liar so we now
have a legal system that incentivizes
false accusations for money but the
trick is easy accuse a prominent person
he'll then deny it you sue him and he'll
give you money and if I had anything to
hide I'd pay money I have nothing to
hide of course I won't pay a penny so
what what do we do exactly about the
kind of perversion of of the system
because this is what is happening is
that it seems like the social sanctions
are being brought to bear in a non legal
sense and so you'll say well my rights
are being violated or my speech is being
violated they'll say well but it's not I
mean you're free to say whatever you
want you're free to do whatever you want
nobody's bothering you it's social
sanctions obviously social sanctions are
perfectly legal the canceled culture
which you're obviously talking about 30
seconds Street why deciding that you
can't speak there because there's an
accusation out there that isn't
unsubstantiated not only associated
disproved right that that attitude it
doesn't have First Amendment
consequences in the sense it's not a
legal thing but it obviously has
widespread societal consequences the
left wishes to ignore those because it
of course likes canceled culture because
it can be applied
people it disagrees with but what do we
have to do about that as a society well
first we have to stand up and fight most
people can't fight back this most people
have something to hide even if you
falsely accused of this if you have
something that you are ashamed of it
will come out at a trial so the vast
majority of people who have falsely
accused can't fight back I'm lucky I was
brought up with the Ducks like you I've
never improperly touched anybody in my
life I don't hug I don't touch I don't
do any of those things
for ten years I was professor at Harvard
Law School as a single man never went
out flirted never had a complaint 50
years never a complaint so I can sue
because I'm not afraid of being deposed
I'm not afraid of anybody coming up with
yet another accuser if there's another
accuser it will be a false accuser
somebody came to me recently in an
extortion attempt presumably by lawyers
offering to sell me pictures of myself
having sex I laughed I said that can't
be a picture of me having sex with
anybody but my wife and they produced
the picture of the the the New York
Times produced the picture it was a joke
you know it was some old guy that they
got off the internet
my wife looked at it and she you know
she laughed hysterically my wife laughed
when we first when I was first accused
she couldn't believe it you know
and this woman who accused me she's
accused Al Gore Al Gore's wife of being
on Epstein's Island they were never on
the island she is accused Bill
Richardson she has accused George
Mitchell she's accused Leslie Wexner she
has accused Marvin Minsky the man who
developed artificial intelligence she's
accused everybody and she's lying
through her teeth she said she was 14
when she met Jeffrey Epstein her own
work records show that she was 17 and
when he allegedly farmed her out to
other people she was almost 19
so she's lied about everything and yet
people believe her because she's a woman
and when I accuse her of lying
I committed a social sin I accused a
woman lying how dare you she was
victimized maybe she was but she's
victimized me and I'm gonna fight back
so yeah I've asked already sort of what
do we do about this but one of the
things that seemed so threatening is
that as I say a lot of this is social
sphere oriented it's it's pressure that
de Tocqueville talked about back in
democracy in America specifically
talking about the idea that social
pressure could be brought to bear to
basically make a human being into a dead
man walking forbidden from all public
company and all of this going back to
the 1830s so it's nothing it's nothing
new what what is new is that there seems
to be a push and it's already happened
in places like Britain in Canada to
actually change the laws to reflect this
sort of very short idle attitude they
should change the laws number one nobody
should be allowed defame other people
behind litigation privilege because they
abuse it they use it all the time
judge compromise the chief judge of the
Second Circuit is written about that
saying don't believe what you read from
court filings court filings don't have
the imprimatur of the court they're just
put in in order to protect themselves
from that kind of defamation so the law
does have to be changed I think the
First Amendment law has to be modified
as well take what CNN did to me that's
not protected by the First Amendment and
it shouldn't be protected if zuker the
head of CNN sat down with his people and
said let's now try to destroy Dershowitz
his credibility because he made a good
speech in front of the Senate
let's wrench out of context let's take
out what he said about criminal conduct
let's make him say something he didn't
say deliberately and willfully I don't
think that's protected by the First
Amendment and for that reason as a First
Amendment person who cares deeply about
the First Amendment I am seriously
considering the possibility of taking
legal action against CNN in order to try
to level the playing field so that the
media can't turn truth tellers into
liars in a willful and deliberate way so
what exactly the First Amendment
standard then look like so under current
law obviously the First Amendment
standard particularly public figures is
extraordinarily burdensome you have to
prove willful and malicious you have to
demonstrate that the person knew that
they were saying something that was
fully untrue true of what happened with
CNN absolutely true they knew what they
were doing they say you don't actually
you're not talking about actually
changing the standard for so here's the
problem what they did is they showed me
saying certain things and I did say
those things it's like I said here's
what I don't believe and then they said
what I said
the leading case in the Supreme Court
involves the New Yorker
magazine where somebody was accused of
taking words out of a quote and the
Supreme Court said that isn't covered by
the First Amendment but we'd have to
make new law by saying that basically if
you use the words that were actually
spoken but you purposely willfully and
with malice leave out words just before
and just after that totally completely
changed the meaning that's not protected
by the First Amendment
and I think that's right okay so that
seems like a fairly minor change that
has already basically been pre-approved
by the Supreme Court you're not talking
about widespread changes of the kind
that President Trump has referred to on
Twitter when he's talking about changing
the full-on standards of defamation no
no I think we start small by looking at
people who willfully and deliberately
abuse the First Amendment for partisan
or personal or financial benefit that's
where you begin and I think we can do
that okay so the other changes that I
was talking about when it comes to sort
of the the you know pushing of social
sanction into the into the matters of
law are these moves that have been made
in places like Canada and United Kingdom
with regard to things like hate speech
they're trying to actually criminalize
forms of speech that supposedly
victimize a protected class and that I'm
deeply worried about happening in the
United States seems like a lot of the
Democratic Party would do that frankly I
don't know how many justices on the
Supreme Court would stand against that
in its current iteration obviously I
think that the ones who were appointed
by Bush and Trump likely would stand
against that I have no idea about Sonia
Sotomayor I have no idea about Elena
Kagan I have a fairly decent idea about
Justice Ginsburg and I think it may go
the wrong way there but that I don't
know where where that stands do you
think that the Supreme Court would
actually allow without a constitutional
amendment hate speech regulations to be
promulgated in the United States depends
on the regulation but I think an
outright banning of something called
hate speech would not survive supreme
court review but you know they chip away
at it
what about in a private university what
about in a public university banning
hate speech in the classroom that would
probably be approved but in the open
forum I think it's going to be a matter
of degree but I do think that the
banning of hate speech has more
legitimacy today on the left than it
ever had before I don't think the left
today
would support the ACL u--'s position
back many years ago he doesn't defending
the rights of not with the ACL you
forget about the ACLU on free speech the
ACLU is free speech for the left but not
for the right except once every ten
years will defend the Nazi because
that's easy and that gives us a little
bit of credibility but due process on
campus forget about it the ACLU is now
the problem not the solution the due
process and free speech so I sort of
want to shift topics here now when I ask
you about your career before everything
Trump related and modern politics
related and I want to ask you about your
criminal law career because obviously
before any of this happened that's what
you were famous for I mean that was the
thing that made you a household name was
was the the von Bulow case or they or
the OJ Simpson case things like that so
I've always wanted to ask you about sort
of the criminal justice system the
adversarial nature of the criminal
justice system so from the outside to
somebody like me I look at it and it
seems like you know the the accusation
was constantly made whoever can find the
best lawyers wins that that if you're a
impoverished defendant and you can't
find a great lawyer you're basically
screwed but if you are a very wealthy
defendant and you've committed egregious
crimes and you can find a good lawyer
that person can squirrel you out of the
charges how much truth is there to that
and does that make the case for a sort
of European inquisitorial system as
opposed to the US justice system which
is adversarial in nature the United
States system is not adversarial at all
ninety seven percent of cases in the
federal courts and then guilty pleas
because of what's called the trial
penalty and the job of the criminal
lawyer today
is to explain the gun that's being held
to the head of the defendant saying if
you don't plead guilty you're gonna get
ten times the amount of jail time that
you would have gotten if you plead
guilty so what I have to do is now
recommend the clients all the time look
if you go to trial you'll get ten years
if you lose if you plead guilty I think
I can get you a year now what's the
chances of me winning well pretty good I
mean I think I got a twenty five thirty
percent chance of winning not good
enough if there's a ten to one ratio so
of course being wealthy gives you the
advantage legally medically housing wise
educationally in every other way why why
should it be different
with the law and that's why I do half of
my cases pro bono I represent half of my
clients from the beginning the day I
started practicing law I've done half of
my cases pro bono representing poor
people obscure people you don't read
about those cases and those cases I've
had actually more success because you
can have more success sometimes with low
visibility cases than with famous cases
famous cases you have to win in court
now we did win von Bulow we didn't win
OJ Simpson we did win I didn't win
Michael Milken who just got a pardon so
maybe we did win ultimately in the end
but you know I've lost cases with rich
people and I've won cases for for poor
people but having money is a knife that
cuts both ways it makes it more likely
that you'll be prosecuted if you're very
rich and if you're a big prize but it
also makes it more likely you'll have a
chance to win the case so and once I can
only ask you as a criminal defense
attorney acting in that capacity how do
you sort of square that with with your
perspective of morality I ask you that
in one second but first let's talk about
sleep quality I'm good at a lot of
things sleep is not one of these things
and that's why I need a mattress that is
made just for me I need the world's best
mattress and that of course is a
personalized mattress personalized
mattresses from helix mattress these are
the best mattresses in fact I got a
helix sleep mattress for my sister as
well for her wedding
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper or a hot sleeper whether
you like a plush or firm bed with helix
there is no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated than
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine and CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on fact check it true that's the first
time CNN has ever said anything true
just go to helix sleep calm slash Ben
take their two minutes leave quiz and
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they've got a ten
year warranty you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free though even pick it
up for you if you don't love it but you
definitely will hulex is offering up to
200 bucks off all mattress orders for
our listeners right now get up to $200
off at helix sleep comm slash Ben that's
helix sleep comm / Ben some molds enough
remember when you are a buck a Bugaboo
the right right I'm I'm not quite that
young but I'm old enough to remember
when the OJ trial happened I remember
them wheeling the TV into my public
school classroom for the
the verdict I think I was maybe 10 at
the time and I remember the in our
household your name was it was a bit of
a dirty word because you were one of the
attorneys defender jeomsun and of course
as everyone who was mainly sent into the
time thought oj simpson was deeply
guilty so yeah i'm not going to ask you
whether oj simpson was guilty because as
her new client privilege but with that
said yet you defend clients and and
criminal defense attorneys or defendant
clients knowing presumably or at least
thinking that they're guilty how do you
square that believing that your own
client has has done something deeply
evil or immoral and then going in and
defending that on it i think much the
same way a catholic priest
defends not turning in a penitent who is
admitted committing a terrible crime the
big difference between a catholic priest
and a lawyer is if a lawyer if a client
tells me I've killed somebody I'm gonna
go and do it again or I've beaten my
wife I'm gonna go back and beat her I'm
obligated to turn him in because it's a
future crime a priest can't do that a
priest says no I'm gonna try to persuade
you and talk you out of it or a doctor
my daughter-in-laws an emergency room
doctor she has almost certainly saved
the lives of people who've gone out and
done terrible things in the future it's
a very important part of our legal
system that everybody get a defense I
uniquely get the most difficult cases
because now I've had some success and
also as a professor I can take more of
these cases of pro bono and so I've had
a lot of people who I've strongly
suspected were probably guilty in a
couple of cases I was pleasantly
surprised at the end klaus von Bulow I
was presently surprised but you know you
talk about not being able to ask me
whether or not Oh Jay did it when I
first when Bibi Netanyahu who I've known
since he's 22 years old became Prime
Minister I was in Israel he invited me
my wife and my daughter to come see him
at his new digs and we went and we
smooths and we took pictures and he took
me into the little private room and said
Alan I have a question I've always
wanted to ask you did oj do it and i
said mr. prime minister this question
i've always wanted to ask you does
Israel have nuclear weapons
[Laughter]
okay so yeah you didn't grow up in a
Jewish school so uh you know with with
regard to that sort of said this is the
reason I asked whether an inquisitorial
system would be better one where it
doesn't seem to pit you know one person
who's now job it is to defend the
criminal conduct of somebody who
believes knew who they believe committed
a criminal act inquisitorial system you
know do you think that the u.s. is the
best system or do you think that it I
think it's the best system for the
United States I wouldn't ever try to
impose our system on foreign countries
by the way many of the countries that
have become free after the breakdown of
the Soviet Union have had an option of
going with the American system with the
European system and many have gone with
the American system you know as
Churchill said about democracy I could
say about the adversary system the worst
ever invented except for all the others
that have been tried over time I think
there is an adversarial relationship
between a person accused of crime and
the state and you can't bury that
adversarial relationship in an in in
paternalism or any other kind of
euphemism there really is a conflict our
job as criminal defense attorneys is to
get the best deal Jeffrey Epstein look
at that I got him a very good deal and I
was hated for it but that's my job if I
had done anything less than get him the
best deal I possibly could I would have
been doing something in violation of my
oath of office and so it creates a moral
conflict I don't sleep well at night
when I defend somebody who I believe
probably did it I've never had a client
who's gone out and done it again that is
committed a second murder or done
something horrible horrible OJ Simpson
obviously was convicted of doing
something but it was fairly minimal and
by the way I don't take a case I don't
represent a person twice I have a rule I
have several rules I don't represent
somebody who was in the business of
crime I don't represent I don't want to
be the consigliere to a crime family I
don't represent drug dealers they don't
represent a professional terrorists or
people like that but I will represent
anybody once regardless of how serious
the crime is now obviously what I
represent a Nazi who killed members of
my family no there'd be a conflict of
interest there I'd you know I'd want so
much to see him convicted but if I have
no personal emotional conflict of
interest I don't let the seriousness of
the crime influence my decision whether
to take
so another area where you've obviously
become very well-known in there a bunch
of different areas because you're sort
of a master of several different trades
isn't it is in the pro-israel space and
right I would suggest you actually that
your unpopularity on the Left began with
the the intervention in the pro-israel
space long before or I think that's
really the president Trump stuff
happened people go know about that
because people who don't follow the
pro-israel sprays don't actually follow
the pro-israel space but as soon as you
wrote the case for Israel it seemed like
the left turned on you or at least a
segment of the left turned on you in
fairly vicious fashion it's right more
the hard left
no I'm Tom ski commission Norman
Finkelstein to try to find problems in
the book and he found a quote from Mark
Twain which I quoted and attributed to
Mark Twain and he said I didn't find it
in Mark Twain I found it in a book by a
woman named John Peters young Peters
whose book had been criticized yeah I
mean first of all we both found it in
the same place we found it in a little
pamphlet called facts and
something-or-other which was put out by
some pro-israel organization which you
couldn't cite obviously because it's not
in libraries but we both found it in the
same place but you know he accused me of
plagiarism I immediately went to Harvard
University the President and said I want
to study Commission I want they
appointed Eric Hauck the former
president of Harvard to investigate the
charge of plagiarism he said there was
nothing to it but that was the first
attempt to attack my integrity because I
supported Israel so what why do you
think it is that the hard left has
turned so so far against Israel why do
you think that's being mainstreamed into
the Democratic Party the scary living
hell out of me frankly we start very
easily the hard left the hard hard left
turn against the common the turn against
Israel in the Communist Party turned
against Israel it was as simple as that
1967 Israel wins the war the Soviet
Union breaks relationships with Israel
the communist parties all over the world
turn against Israel because they're
taking orders from Stalin it's it's
simpler not Stalin in those days but the
Stalinists in those days
it was as simple as that back then then
beragon I write about this in my book
called defending Israel beragon who is a
paragon of the left during the Vietnam
War calls Israel a criminal community a
Jewish criminal community so you get
beragon Chomsky Finkelstein Eli that's
moan the hard hard left turn against
Israel and then it creeps into the
Center left and you get people like
Peter beinhart who become enemies of
Israel though they proclaim that they're
really Zionists J Street which has never
said anything positive about Israel in
any of its press releases and and
supported the Goldstone report and
they've now made it possible for
Democrats to say we're not gonna go to a
pack of Liz Warren says I'm not going to
a pack so I think the democratic party
we were in danger of seeing the
bipartisan support for Israel weakened
as the result of the left of the
Democratic Party I think this is one of
the things people are missing so I hear
this a lot from Democrats who are Jews
which is the vast majority of Jews are
Democrats is that the the reason that
the Democrats are turning against Israel
is because of Trump and that's
completely neglecting the history of the
Democratic Party which was wildly
pro-israel throughout at least the early
1990s and then it began to move and
shift you can see this in the opinion
polls and and by the time Barack Obama
was president it didn't move fairly
fairly solidly into the Palestinian camp
at least in terms of being on parity
with Israel in terms of popularity
inside the Democratic Party this is
particularly true among young Democrats
and Obama obviously facilitated that and
President Obama was not a fan of the
State of Israel he hated Prime Minister
Netanyahu obviously the attempt to pin
that on President Trump is pretty
astonishing again considering that that
the mainstream Democratic Party had been
moving in this direction for quite a
while labeling Israel an apartheid state
and no doubt about that and I think
President Obama for whom I voted twice I
now would reconsider my second vote for
him he he conned me he called me into
the Oval Office and he said I have
Israel's back and I didn't realize what
he meant is to put a target on it and
stab him as he was leaving office he
ordered his representative to the UN to
not veto a resolution which declared the
Kotel the western wall the holiest place
of Judaism to be occupied territory
along with the access roads the Hebrew
University and the Hadassah Hospital and
the Jewish quarter was outrageous
outrageous and it just legitimated more
and more people in the Democratic Party
saying well we should have a balance the
Palestinians who have turned down
statehood since 38 48 60
790 two thousand two thousand one two
thousand seven two thousand eight so I
think the Democratic Party now there's a
real danger of losing the bipartisan
support I think there are some many
centrist Democrats who still support
Israel but people on the left and
younger people to a far far lesser
extent on this is why it's driving me up
a wall to watch Bernie Sanders try and
play on the fact that he's ethnically
Jewish as though he's some sort of
Patriot on behalf of either Israel or
Jews I mean it's just it's maddening to
watch considering again that the man
campaigns openly with open anti-semite
SiC Linda Sarsour and nailhead Omar and
receded to leave and well you left out
one he went to England and campaigned
for Jeremy Corbyn who facilitated turned
the Labour Party into a party that
welcomed anti-semites and Bernie Sanders
went there campaigned for him let me
take one other' as a Democrat in no
circumstances will I ever vote for
Bernie Sanders period I will never vote
for Bernie Sanders and I would hope that
other Democrats would join me in that
pledge because he would hurt America
terribly and I think in the end he would
ferment some anti-semitism because he
would hurt America so badly and for the
first Jewish president to hurt our
economy and hurt our standing in the
world I think would be just a terrible
terrible thing I'm not going to vote
against him because he's Jewish
obviously I am going to vote against him
because his policies are so deleterious
to what has made America great America
thrives at the center we are a great
country Franklin Roosevelt was one of
our greatest presidents because he
avoided what was going on in Europe and
Europe you're either communist or
fascist the center disappeared Roosevelt
in the 30s created a kind of social
capitalism which allowed for us to
preserve centrist democracy says summers
Democratic Party and I think we're
seeing that hurt my new book that I'm
working on why I left the left but
couldn't join the right the case for the
vibrant center I try to bring us back to
Center as politics centers conservative
centrist liberal and avoid marginalize
the extremes on both sides but Sanders
is the extreme
on the left side so because of my own
personal politician who spends a lot of
time here sort of bashing the Democratic
Party in the left but what do you think
the right gets wrong because obviously
the title of the new book is that you're
not joining the right so well what do
you think the right gets wrong well you
know we have differences you're an
Orthodox religious person I support a
woman's right to choose I support gay
marriage and gay rights I a strong
supporter of following the science on
the environment of reasonable gun
control of health care as broad as
possible consistent with our economic
welfare so I pretty much go down the
liberal agenda when it comes to social
issues on the other hand when it comes
to foreign policy
if I were in Britain I'd be a
conservative be easy for me because the
Conservative Party in Britain follows
many of the social policies that we
talked about but I'm in a great conflict
I love the evangelical Christians yes
they're so supportive of Israel and they
are so respectful of me when I speak at
Liberty University and I talk about a
woman's right to choose
I get polite applause when I talk about
gay marriage a polite applause when I
mentioned Israel I got a 15-minute
standing ovation
so I feel politically homeless I feel
thrust out I from what Ronald Reagan
said I didn't leave the Democrats and
Democrats left me they are quickly
leaving me I don't feel I feel welcome
in the conservative or republican party
but I don't feel comfortable with the
social conservatism of so many
Republicans I'd love to see return to
kind of Eisenhower republicanism
Rockefeller republicanism but we're not
seeing it so I want to ask you about
sort of your system of values so you
grew up Orthodox right but obviously
you're not Orthodox now so what is your
sort of religious belief system because
obviously you're very not only
identifiably Jewish but obviously you
speak in terms of Judaism a lot so so
where do you hold on this I love my
Judaism I love going to synagogue I'm a
traditional Jew but I'm skeptic I'm a
skeptic about atheism I'm a skeptic
about God the God I'm skeptical about is
the Jewish God I'm skeptical about
atheism I don't call myself anything
agnostic atheist I'm not an atheist
because I'm too skeptical
I'm skeptical about science I'm
skeptical you took my course with a
Steven Pinker II a long time ago at
Harvard you know that I'm skeptical
about everything I'm skeptical about
evolution explaining every
in biology I'm gonna die a skeptic I'm
gonna die not knowing the answers to all
these questions but I hope I'm still
healthy enough and wise enough to keep
asking the question so my religion is
skepticism so how do you generate a
moral system based on skepticism I
remember I remember asking this question
I think I actually raised my hand in our
class and ask you this question
specifically I wrote a book an answer to
your question called rights from wrongs
I know I read it because it was very
class right so it's a secular theory of
the development of Rights through
experience in history my theory is that
rights grow out of a recognition of the
wrongs and if you look historically the
civil rights movement goes out of
slavery the post holocaust movement of
human rights around the world I think
that I'm an experiential estai I'm a
strong supporter I didn't like him
personally but Oliver Wendell Holmes the
life of the law is not logic its
experience and you learn from your
mistakes and so I think my theory of
Rights grows out of my understanding of
how to avoid the wrongs in the world but
I'm not an absolutist so I got into a
lot of trouble when I suggested that
under certain circumstances a torture
warrant might be permissible if for
example we had a terrorist who had
planted a nuclear bomb in New York or
Los Angeles that could kill 10 million
people and we had the terrorists and we
could by use of extreme measures prevent
that from happening I suggested the
possibility of a torture warrant which
got me into a lot of trouble with all my
liberal friends many of them said we
agree with you privately but don't ever
say that publicly so I'm not an
absolutist but I have a strong
presumption against torture against
censorship against a range of other
denials of civil liberties
so in a second I only ask you about sort
of that that perspective on rights vs.
wrongs especially because I wanna know
how you how you don't slip into a sort
of historicism if the idea is that we're
constantly developing and learning from
our wrongs does that mean inevitably
we're going to get better because human
history seems to say no I want to ask
you about that in one second first let's
talk about protecting your internet data
so the reality is you wouldn't leave
your front door unlocked at night
because somebody might break in and you
wouldn't leave your car unlocked on the
street somebody might break in why would
you leave your Internet
activity unprotected did you know for
example that your internet service
provider logs every single website you
visit they can sell that information to
ad companies and tech giant's who could
use the data to target you expressvpn
puts a stop to all of this it creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the Internet so that your
online activity can't be seen by anyone
else expressvpn works on all your
devices phones laptops routers so
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can still
be protected even if they are not using
expressvpn themselves the best part is
using Express VPN is super simple did
you go try it it really is easy I've
been using it for years of myself so if
you're like me and you believe that your
online activity is your business secure
yourself by visiting expressvpn comm
slash been today use my exclusive link
expressvpn comm slash ban expr ESS VPN
comm slash ben and you can get an extra
three months for free right now
that's expressvpn comm slash been so and
ask about the basis of a positive
morality because obviously in order to
identify the wrong you do have to
actually identify the wrong based on
something right we see bad things happen
around the world and people justify them
routinely i mean there's been thousands
of years of bad things happening in most
places on the globe and there are
thousands more for thousands more for
virtually all places on the globe before
that so what is the moral system based
on other than there have to be some
fundamental precepts in other words that
undergird how we decide when the thing
is wrong so Robert Nozick was one of my
closest friends on the faculty a great
philosopher of libertarianism and I gave
him a draft shortly before he died of my
book on rights from wrongs and he
pointed out as you pointed out can you
really know what wrongs are without
knowing what rights are and my answer is
yes I think there is a human instinct
that really teaches us when something is
wrong and everybody agrees that now of
course they didn't overtime slavery was
wrong and the Holocaust was wrong
anti-gay bashing is wrong but you never
get agreement about what's right it's
much easier to find agreement on what's
a dystopia than a utopia take for
example a utopia from a labor and
economic point of view you couldn't get
ten people sitting in a room deciding
what the best system of economic
regulation is but I think most of us
today would agree that socialism and
communism has proved
it's the wrong approach so we get a much
wider consensus on what's wrong than
what's right but look it's a work in
progress I don't think it's a perfect
solution when I once argued with Scalia
Justice Scalia who I became friendly
with that his system of originalist
isn't perfect it doesn't solve Brown
versus Board of Education he said look
it's not perfect but it's better than
the others and it's safer than the
others and he had a point there and I
think my system may be better than the
others but it's not perfect well what's
interesting about your system is that it
actually wouldn't we're talk about
rights versus wrong actually not talking
about individual rights versus wrongs
you're talking about moral that's
morally correct versus morally wrong and
it seems that the American system the
Enlightenment based system is based on
not moral right versus moral wrong it's
based on individual rights so where does
the regime of individual rights come in
and do you think that individuals have
rights or is it basically sort of a
perky and experientialism well you know
I think there's a there are elements of
both you know you you had my class with
Steve Pinker Steve Pinker really
believes that we are moving in the right
direction he's written this brilliant
book on how everything is gone right
better angels are nature yeah but you
know having lived through the Holocaust
I was a child but my family lived
through it and many of them were killed
i I just don't see it as a direct line
in fact the Jewish experience has always
been things get better and then they get
much worse then they get a little better
then they get much worse you know the
the Jewish definition of a pessimist is
Oy things are so bad they can't possibly
get worse and an optimist says yes they
can so I'm a Jewish optimist I think
things could get worse and we have
control over our destiny we determine
whether things get better or get worse
so you're a religious person in the end
I mean that's that's pretty real murder
and Steven Pinker would say there's no
such thing as free will and so young
it's all in your head and all that by
that and religious in the sense of I'm
skeptical I'm gonna get you keeping
Travis Python oh I love Shabbos and one
of my favorite books was joe lieberman's
book about Shabbos how the Jews haven't
kept the Sabbath but the Sabbath has
kept the Jews
I think the Sabbath is a fantastic
invention I just was in the synagogue
reading from the Ten
Commandments and whoever heard of a
commandment that says you have to rest
one day a week at dozen salient
commandment it sounds like a labor
organization you know platform program
but it is a commandment and it's a very
wise commandment so you taught at you
know the law school for decades let me
see now have you seen a change in the
nature of the students who are coming
through because one of the great
questions is I've been speaking on
campuses now for probably 20 years at
this point somewhere in that
neighborhood 15 20 years and even I in
the last 15 years have seen a massive
change in sort of how treatment on
campus has has been I used to be able to
speak on campus no security whatsoever
that's right I can like 2010/2011 here I
remember I spoke at Berkeley in 2015 and
it was fine I came back in 2016 we
required 600 police officers in a
$600,000 security expenditure by the
City of Berkeley in order to prevent
riots remember though what what example
con that issue that it's one word one
word truth the left knows the truth with
a capital T and if you know the truth
why do you need the sense what do you
need opposing points of view if you know
the truth
what do you need do process what do you
need to have a system of determining
what happened we know the truth the
truth is if you're a white male you're
guilty if you're a woman of color you're
a victim we know the truth that's what's
happening on campuses today and
universities are no longer places where
teachers teach you how to think they
teach you what to think 50 years of
teaching I think you'll recognize four
of my class nobody knew what my personal
views weren't almost anything I would
raise question after question there was
never a right answer in my class it was
simply a method of challenging
everything skepticism about everything
today you have teachers showing students
what to believe and it's propaganda it's
not education and it seems to me that
when it comes to what's happening on
campus so much of it is focused on
undermining exactly the sort of rights
that you've spent your life defending
those rights are now seen as a bulwark
of a hierarchical system you see people
arguing against freedom of speech on
sort of mark you see and principal herb
are accused thinnest Frankfurt School
philosopher arguing that that free
speech itself was a reinforcement of the
hierarchy because the people who took
best advantage
that were the privilege I remember
Marcus he taught at Brandeis when I
started teaching at Harvard and he was
propagandizing the students back then
against free speech and now you have
professors who are saying that free
speech is a male hierarchical ID you
know all the words you can just make
them up as you go along because that's
what they do but it's no good
we don't need free speech we don't need
due process I've never seen that before
on university campuses even during the
McCarthy period the people on the right
would be apologetic about denying due
process the people on the hard left
aren't apologetic they think it's the
right thing so what do you think is the
future of higher education then because
I know that we're trying to shovel
everybody into into higher education is
seemingly to to less and less effect but
do you think that eventually people are
gonna wake up and realize that this is
largely a waste of time unless you're
majoring in maths and science and that's
what they're doing that's what they're
doing the good students are staying away
from majoring in anything but Computer
Sciences math economics and in some
universities basically universities are
two universities now that have the
serious students who are really
interested in learning and it's mostly
in the science side and then you have
the students who know for in Harvard you
have to work so hard to get a b-minus I
mean it's almost impossible you could
just walk through Harvard and get B's
and B pluses and a's and everything and
then come out with your harvard degree
and learn absolutely nothing if you're a
Jewish kid you can major in Jewish
Studies and just repeat what you learned
in elementary school in high school if
you're a woman you can major in women's
studies and have all your professors say
Wow
oh isn't that great aren't no criticism
and and these kind of ethnic studies
programs are so dangerous I mean I would
practically have a rule saying all right
you can have ethnic studies but if
you're Jewish you can't take Jewish
Studies if you're black you can't take
Black Studies if you're a woman you
can't take women's studies that's
available for other people to learn
about you now that's nonsense of course
because obviously if you're an
african-american you have a right to
learn about your culture and your
history but so how am I gonna be chosen
to learn about right
Thanks well you know I said when I see
you say late that's how you met the
Jewish girls who went to Jewish Studies
class well you'll like this the reason I
wrote my book the case for Israel is a
kid came over to me one day and he asked
me to give him qu ba was during the ten
days of repentance he said because he
never speaks out in class in support of
Israel though he knows a lot and I said
why not he said yes I won't ever get a
date so I started a campaign I said
support Israel date a Zionist tonight
it helped a bunch of Zionists get dates
but it didn't really help the cause of
it so you mentioned your sort of
constitutional theory of interpretation
and you mentioned Justice Scalia
originalism or textualism I think
frankly that Justice Thomas is more of
an originalist than Scalia was so so
what what is your theory of how the
Constitution should be interpreted by
the Supreme I think there are you know
Scalise constitutions dead tribe says
it's alive they're both wrong part of
it's dead part of it's alive
the part about 35 years old being
president you couldn't be deader than
that of course it's dead you can't be 34
and 11 and take the oath of office due
process the process that is due is an
invitation to change what due process
means over the years
for example the framers of the
Fourteenth Amendment none of them would
have said that that means black and
white children go to school together and
get married oh my god you wouldn't got
one vote for that so of course due
process has to change over time
impeachment I think it's dead I think
impeachment is dead it should never
change over time the framers said
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors meaning other crimes like
treason and bribery it's dead it doesn't
change in the 19th century people
thought it needed a crime the Dean of
the Columbia Law School said the weight
of authorities in favor of you need a
crime the former Justice of the Supreme
Court defended Andrew Johnson you need a
crime suddenly we've gotten woke and all
the professor's when Trump isn't pizza
crime you don't even need a sin you can
call it a abuse of power 40 of our
presidents have been accused of abusing
their power they want to normalize
impeachment turn it into a partisan
weapon to become part of our political
system exact
what Madison and Hamilton rejected they
said we don't want to turn into a
British parliamentary system where a
president serves at the pleasure of the
legislature and yet that's exactly what
the Democrats try to introduce I mean I
really was amazed by the weakness of the
charges that they brought forth in the
house because I figured that if they
were going to actually charge the
president with I mean they kept saying
bribery over and over I don't know was
charged with bribery man torsion right
if they'd done that my argument would
have been completely different I don't
know that I would have argued but once
they charge them with abuse of power my
god obstruction of Congress every lawyer
obstructs Congress whenever he demands a
court order before allowing his client
to fall into a perjury trap I know I do
that all the time
and so those were two vague general
Madison Hamilton would be turning over
in their graves
moreover Hamilton said the greatest
danger is that impeachment will become
partisan they both wanted all of them
wanted impeachment to occur only when
there was a bipartisan support that's
why any two-thirds in the Senate and
overwhelming national support for
impeachment the only case for
impeachment that ever should have gone
forward was Richard Nixon so in the
future do you think that impeachment is
gonna happen every couple of years or
anything not every couple of years but
every decade whenever you get a
president of one party and a house of
another party and the president's
controversial there's going to be a move
to impeach remember that we're going to
impeach Hillary Clinton on day one
republicans were yelling lock her up
it started in some ways with the
impeachment of Clinton now Clinton did
was accused of a crime perjury but it
wasn't a high crime it was a low crime
it was perjury committed not in his
official capacity holding office but in
his personal capacity so with that said
and it seems like the country is getting
more partisan you're hoping for a center
do you see that emerging anytime soon or
not in my lifetime
your lifetime I think will see the
pendulum swing slowly in America and I
think the rest of my life will be living
in a division country look when I turned
75 six years ago I thought I was gonna
have such a nice retirement and then I
get used falsely and then Trump gets
elected now
my family doesn't talk to me people on
the vineyard don't talk to me
my wife was mad at me for taking the
case you know it's one of the chapters
in my new book is the cost of trying to
live a principled life and it's very
very hard to do but I mean I'm too old
to change
well again since I apparently this
episode is devoted to me trying to get
to I'm gonna fromyou up before the end
you want to be popular all you have to
do is go to a from show it's they are
you I might the synagogue I go to is
Park East in New York the Cantor is this
incredible Cantor named health got the
rabbi is this incredible rabbi named
schneier and I go there and I like it I
love the melodies I give the DVAR Torah
but I'm a skeptic but I'm told
rabbis right that's okay that's all
right you can do that that's all right
well I I do want to ask you one more
question I ask you since you have all of
these various legacies in various areas
what do you want
the chief legacy of Alan Dershowitz to
be but if you want to hear Alan
Dershowitz his answer you have to be a
daily wire member so to become a member
head on over to daily wire comment click
Subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation there well professor
Dershowitz thank you so much for your
time and thank you so much for stopping
by I really appreciate you thank you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike joiner and produced by
mantas Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring associate producer case Winterton
our guests are booked by Caitlyn Manor
post-production is supervised by Alex's
Singaram editing is by Jim nickel audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Nika Geneva title graphics are by
Cynthia Angulo the Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you
[Music]